Hello Freak bitches.
There's a,
the guy who was the doctor behind that movie concussion,
he was recently talking about Oj Simpson because Oj Simpson was released and
he's like,
this is 100% chance that guy has CTE.
And they've even said that Oj,
if the trial was today,
his doctor said that he would introduce CTE as a defense,
which is crazy because then you have to say he's guilty because the defense was
always,
I didn't do it,
you know?
And he wrote a book how I did it.
Yeah.
If I did it,
that was the book.
I know.
But anF is in tiny little red mark.
And I did it.
I watched the CH,
the Cuba Gooding show last night,
the FX show.
I'd never seen it.
Never seen people versus Oj Simpson.
It was a great record.
Yeah.
Great show.
You know,
it's Weird Watch,
man.
Just to revisit everything like woof,
the night when the Oj got out,
it's like,
just go away.
Yeah.
Just go quiet.
Don't say anything.
Play Golf and keep your mouth shut.
He can do,
he's not going to and you can't.
He's,
uh,
he's addicted to love.
He's addicted to people liking them.
And there's going to always,
if he goes to Florida,
there's plenty of fucking stupid people in forest go and make them right there
or he's going back to jail.
He's gonna do something stupid and violate his parole.
Do you think you'll do that though?
It's seven years old or whatever he is.
Well,
if he does anything other than shut up,
he's either going to die or go back to jail.
You know what I mean?
Like there's no,
there's no positive that's going to come out of him making public appearances,
you know,
writing a book,
going on a talk show circuit.
Like,
no,
like you're 78 years old,
live out the last 10,
15,
20 years,
whatever he got with just live it.
There isn't,
there's money somewhere,
right.
Cause Florida,
they couldn't take his money there.
So yeah,
he's gotten money somewhere.
Just,
just quietly fade away.
You know,
let people,
people might recognize you when you go down to play Bingo at the home.
Just wave banks Marlboro.
And,
uh,
you know,
but,
but yeah,
there's no,
I don't think there's any way.
There's no positive public appearance.
No.
That Oj could make make.
It was,
it was a really,
really intense,
and during that time,
two of his friends die within two weeks of each other of heart attacks at age 52
and 59.
And Nikita Kemiah,
of WHO's 52 years old and he's running,
he had resigned from running the Russian antidoping agency.
So,
so technically the Russian anti-doping agencies shouldn't be working with
Gregory's lab.
The Wada,
the world antidoping agency lab low should be two independent things.
But these two were working together because there was never any anti-doping.
Russia was the anti anti doping system posing as anti-doping.
So Nikita is still in Russia.
He's been forced to resign and Gregory and him are still talking via,
uh,
via Skype.
Um,
and,
uh,
Nikita tells Gregory that he's going to go,
but he's writing a book and that he's been in contact with David Walsh.
And David Walsh is the Sunday Times journalists that chased Armstrong for 10
years.
He's probably one of the most renowned famous sports journalists in the world.
The,
that Stephen Frears film,
the programs based on David Walsh and send,
Nikita had reached out to David Walsh and him and David Walsh,
we're making a plan to meet.
And Nikita had told Gregory that,
you know,
he was going to meet with David Walsh.
Gregory was like,
this is,
you can't do this.
You're still in Russian.
Nikita,
you're still in Russia.
What are you doing?
And a,
a day later,
Nikita dies of a heart attack.
And this was a guy who was healthy,
uh,
had never had a heart problem in his life,
was a,
it was a lifelong athlete.
Never end.
He was 52 52 and apparently he died over about three and a half hours while,
uh,
Nikita's wife was on the phone to Gregory crying.
Uh,
so this is a really have any suspicion of how they did it.
Um,
you know,
Gregory goes out and they just,
you just die of a heart attack,
that poison yo,
whatever.
That,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know how they do it,
but you know,
Russia isn't like Isis.
They don't do something and then take responsibility and obviously,
you know,
there's been so many stories I can buzz feed last year then of the 14 deaths in
London all tied to,
you know,
various had the series of Russia.
There's been multiple books,
written audit,
um,
even,
uh,
you know,
which was not widely reported.
Um,
the Russian agent,
the Co offered a,
apparently the Trump dossier with the mic [inaudible] the former have my six
agent.
Uh,
he was found dead in the back of Alexis about five months ago outside of Moscow.
Um,
so,
you know,
uh,
clearly they,
they,
they play by a different set of rules.
If you look at how men and women evolved to get partners,
women just have to look hot.
You have to look like you're fertile and young and have good genes,
which is what we consider beauty.
These what feminists say are arbitrary standards of beauty.
Aren't anything like that.
They're very across cultures.
Men like women with this hourglass figure and who have long shiny hair and who
are not 72,
because if you had sex with a 72 year old,
your genes died out.
Yeah.
This the feminist thing about arbitrary standards of beauty as a person who is
deeply entrenched in science,
like that's gotta be frustrating,
right?
Because you're looking at something that's not accurate.
It's,
it's a,
you're pushing a narrative that's just not accurate.
There's this very takeaway called Jered takeaway.
You know,
all the,
all your personal feelings about human beings.
And you look at the mammal,
the human mammal,
and it's,
it's very clear why the certain males are gravitating towards certain females
and contrary or,
uh,
conversely,
why certain females are gravitating towards certain males.
It's biological,
right?
And this,
it's so unhelpful.
It's really awful.
This idea that people should like you for Watson.
Now on the inside,
we don't see that people,
um,
if you look at porn,
it's not the woman who buys a homeless man a sandwich.
You know who in the porn,
it's the woman with those features that are just cross culturally appreciated by
men.
Well,
what's also too,
we're talking only about sexual,
right?
Because people do like you for who you are on the inside.
Like Melissa McCarthy is a perfect example.
She's as vibrant,
hilarious woman and no one's,
no one's holding her up as the standard of beauty or sexual attractiveness.
You know,
you're,
you're looking at her as this fun person and that's why millions of people go
see her in movies and her TV shows as giant hit mean it's literally what's on
the inside and how she carries herself.
Right.
And she is very vibrant.
And if you look at that cross cultural research,
David Buss who is an evolutionary psychologist,
did the big,
big cross cultural study and kindness was what both men and women wanted.
I think that was the top,
the top of each list.
But if you prioritize,
well,
okay,
well what do I,
what are my must haves in a partner?
A guy is not going to want a very old,
unattractive woman as his partner.
If he can do better.
And a woman is not going to but want to have the guy who was sleeping in
grandma's basement playing Atari,
Atari or whatever.
I'm a girl,
so I don't know anything about football or video games.
You know?
I'm sure when you're,
you were a sex addict and you're in this hedonistic,
you know,
whirlwind experience,
you're still,
you're taking in all this data and you're taking all this in,
in the hollow feeling that you had that you didn't like.
It is what propelled you to your new stage of consciousness once you emerge from
it.
Yeah,
that's right.
Every so often,
like because he's like pleasure laden an orgy.
I mean,
that's the point of it.
there's flesh everywhere.
It's this bits of it.
They're brilliant.
I was no in,
hold on a minute.
This isn't working.
And this is a thing of what would really,
really work.
You know,
like sometimes the,
the great gift of promiscuity is you get to experience the intimacy with all of
these strangers and it seemed exciting.
And the type of sexuality that I've always had is more about worship then any
kind of domination I adore.
I adore,
you know,
so it's not about like I want to control you.
So like by like the answer to all these wonderful experiences and encounters,
but within this kind of ongoing seam of loneliness on ignorable and also this is
the thing,
when you get the things your culture tells you you should be doing and you
experience them now you know,
now you know you can stop chasing the carrot because you've had a bite out of it
and he's like,
oh,
mini bullshit.
Like you know,
not an,
it's a hard one to learn because anything that's got an orgasm at the end of it,
you know,
there's a degree of pleasure to be had,
but it takes,
it takes a while to recognize or what they see the emotional cost and made a
spiritual cost on other people.
The fact faculty,
it's preventing me from becoming a father,
from becoming husband,
from set lien,
from becoming rooted,
from becoming actually whole,
from becoming a man,
from becoming connected.
And it takes a while to spot that.
I think a lot of people don't get the opportunity to break out that pattern.
I would never have spotted it.
Had a not first being a heroin addict and going,
hold on a minute.
You're doing that thing again.
Same with fame and celebrity.
Well,
toxic,
well toxic,
excited and brilliant and loads of lovely people in there.
And I still like,
you know,
I might make another film,
I don't know what happened,
but like it's because I'd had the template and the experiences of awe,
this is addiction.
You're expecting this thing to make you feel better.
Now what's happening is I am as a baseline disabused of the idea that the
material world,
we'll give me anything that it will ever fulfill me,
that I am responsible for my own connection and that my role here is to serve
other people and help them.
Yeah.